I'm curious how old are your your
children are quite young they're yeah
six and seven six and seven yeah do they
know what you do for I I tried for the
longest time to have my kids who were a
little older than that not know what I
did for a living I just wanted them to
think that I worked in insurance or mode
Lawns or something just a normal Dad
yeah I want to distance myself from Show
Business do they know what you do for a
living have you tried to make it normal
for them yeah it's a ongoing um struggle
but and it gets harder the awareness
kicks in um in the beginning they
thought we pretty much just worked
trailers and sat around which works well
CU When they'd see you you'd be in a
trailer sitting around yeah exactly and
then they would work out you know
sometimes mommy and daddy would do a
disturbing movie and you know have
wounds on them so which is not good for
your
children traumatic um so I would have
them come to the set and help make me up
you know like throw the chocolate powder
on me for dirt and pour blood on me
particularly when I was was filming The
Impossible which was you know many
wounds you know that could go either way
it could be more normal for them or you
could have done the worst thing
ever I see them in therapy mother had us
paint her in
blood you know that could it could go
either way well I you're right and I
really wrestled with the idea of them
seeing me on set at all but it was I was
on that set for five months so it
wouldn't have been good not to see no
not good at all K I'm trying to see have
they seen any of your movies
think like King Kong King Kong that
would have been the only one that was
you know like worth of interest to them
and they do ask about it we read the
book The King Kong book um but there's
still mommy's not in good shape she's
being attacked and by a giant M yeah and
there's that's a scary move that's a
scary scary movie yeah they your kids do
not want to see you in danger and I did
make a mistake and at one point thought
okay because they were asking so much
about it mommy and the monkey and sounds
cute um and then like not really a
monkey a 90 foot tall killer ape exactly
yeah um and then they I so I thought
I'll try the trailer and it was when I
was being sacrificed to King Kong and
that image came up of me screaming and
being tied to some kind of you know
steak or something and and um and it I
could see it was it was traumatic for
him and it was you know that I switched
it off right away and I thought not for
another 5 years at least I mean there's
really no Advantage for them to see
movies at all at any time they look at
clips of this show and they get
scared they're terrified of Andy
uh we all have our Apes
[Applause]
yeah MH he